un weekend bien hivernal la neige s'est
invitée dans le département dans la nuit
du vendredi 4 au samedi 5 mars par
endroit le manteau né jeux a atteint
jusqu'à 5 cm compliquant les conditions
de circulation en ce jour de retour de
vacances pour la zone C Météo France
avait placé les ivelines le valdoise en
alerte orange dès le vendredi soir dans
la foulée la préfecture des ivelines a
donné quelques consignes de sécurité aux
habitants privilégier les transports en
commun ou stationner son véhicule en
dehors des voies de circulation pour
faciliter le passage des engins de
salage même si la neige a tenue
temporairement sur la chaussée ceux qui
prenaient le volant ont dû faire preuve
d'une extrême vigilance à cause du
verglas cet épisode neigjeux est à ce
jour le plus notable de cet hiver en
région parisienne un phénomène causé par
ce que les météorologues appellent un
retour d'occlusion un minimum
dépressionnaire passé entre la Picardie
et le nord de l'île-defance donnant ses
chutes de neige l'alerte a été levé
samedi en fin de matinée Météo France ne
prévoit pas de nouvelles grosses chutes
cette semaine mais invite à rester
vigilant